okay let's take a break from the world
of lies coming to us from the White
House about the virus let's look at
science all right if you've been
watching our show you would already know
about a bunch of possible treatments not
game changers the way Trump is saying
we're talking about possible coronavirus
treatments the question has mostly been
are these safe enough to use in proper
clinical trials and when might that
start the World Health Organization is
starting an unprecedented quadruple
clinical trial where doctors around the
world can participate this is called
solidarity I don't know if that is an
acronym for something it may be maybe
not this is basically taking what would
often be a very long process and
compressing it into simultaneous trials
they are not blinded trials we'll talk
about that in a second and four
different treatments are going to be
tried because we have so many patients
you can try four different things at
once compared to placebo and the
standard treatment in this case they may
not be using placebo that maybe you're
unethical given the circumstances
thousands of patients across multiple
countries are going to be included now
this is being done both to consider
these drugs as treatments for people who
are already sick but also with the
possibility that maybe some of these
could become prophylactics in advance of
a vaccine to protect people from the
virus we don't know that's what's being
tested all right the for drugs being
tested would be familiar to anyone who's
been watching our show since I told you
about these weeks ago we've got the
antiviral rim des aveer that's from
Gilead pharma developed for Ebola didn't
work well for Ebola going to be tested
in this large w-h-o clinical trial
number two I already spoke about it
chloroquine or hydroxychloroquine
another form of the same drug around
since 1934 used to treat malaria side
effects can include muscle problems loss
of appetite diarrhea and skin rash
serious side effects can include vision
issues
so damage seizures low blood cell levels
which itself can lead to subsequent
problems small tests showed it worked on
a small sample of coronavirus patients
it was not blinded and it was not
randomized now there will be more
testing done in combination with as a
thorough Meissen number three a
combination of two HIV drugs lo pin aver
and ritonavir that's the third trial
that's being done and then lastly the
fourth test will be those two HIV drugs
lepen la Penna vert and ritonavir with
the addition of interferon beta doctors
will be able to put their patients
information into a w-h-o computer system
see who's eligible for which test
account for underlying conditions which
may make someone not a good candidate
for one test but may be an okay
candidate for another this is a massive
major undertaking this is the large
trial that we've been waiting for which
starts this week now of course looking
at already approved drugs drugs approved
for other things is going to be the
fastest path much faster than developing
new drugs for sure but then in addition
they are also looking at adding trials
of drugs that have not yet been approved
but that have worked well in animal
trials on other types of respiratory
viruses MERS SARS etc so as I mentioned
again these are not double-blind tests
double-blind would be neither the doctor
nor the patient knows who's getting
which treatment the idea is you prevent
a placebo effect you prevent the doctor
from consciously or subconsciously
giving the trial treatment to patients
that may be predisposed to do better
anyway that would skew the data but
still this is the way it's being done a
number of medical ethicists including
our friend from NYU Arthur Caplan say
given the circumstances this this is a
good test so as always none of these
things will give us answers as soon as
we would like the sooner you start the
sooner you get data the sooner you can
start to figure out whether one of these
may be a good path forward sometimes
when you do this you will very quick
we see one of these four treatments is
significantly better than the standard
treatment and significantly better than
the other treatments that are being
tested when the results are overwhelming
in these emergency situations you will
sometimes see the case made that you
need to drastically expand giving
patients the treatment that appears to
be working we just don't know yet then
you have to start dealing with supply
and distribution issues all sorts of
other things those would be figured out
so that's the big trial going on
unprecedented quadruple clinical trial
we'll see what comes from it let's have
realistic expectations make sure for
more on these trials follow the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show while you're there follow me on
instagram at david pakman to see what
i've been up to during the during the
self quarantine privacy calm is one of
our sponsors and they're giving you
$5.00 just for using their free service
at privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's
of service I've been using for a while
now I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back
rewards extra security features but go
ahead and sign up for the free service
it's a no-brainer companies can't charge
you unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman